au pire était à venir max gallo le pire
est toujours sur le pire est sûre comme
vous êtes quelqu'un de cultivé
d'intelligent de briand bien sûr on va
vous faire l'interview nul lumière sinon
plein ne bouge pas mal au jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo bon là je dois dire ah ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui se maîtrisent parfaitement
maniable il n'a pas cillé
pendant leurs carcasses comme ça ils
mobile d'embêtements total reste des
bons l'interview nul d'ibm à l'interview
nul alors est ce que vous préférez c'est
commence avec ce sur quoi commencer
c'est toujours des choix c'est votre
surnom alors est ce que vous préférez
quand on vous appelle le malraux des
campings ou le michelez d'hypermarchés
au cette équivalence peut-être le mal
rôde et camping préféré le malheureux de
lyon bien dormir sous la tente très bien
là tu dois dire un truc normalement
alors il le dit mais l'effet est ce que
vous préfériez votre père votre mère la
mère jusqu'à 14 ans le père après la
bonne réponse vous préférez hitler ou
staline est ce que je préfère mourir
dans une chambre à gaz ou dans un
chaudron
ouais je sais pas donc c'est des formes
de mort je peux pas choisir entre
méforme de mort est-ce que vous
préféreriez on se concentre je pressens
centre tout ferrari être incarnée en
françois hollande ou en jacques toubon
je préfère leur donne la mort définitive
ouais nan là il faut choisir faut
choisir françois hollande françois
hollande pourtant il n'est pas tendre
avec vous françois hollande il est pas
tendre avec moi mais je les ai vus
naître à la politique
ouais car le hasard fait les choses
quand j'ai été porte parole du
gouvernement il était mon directeur de
cabinet avaient donc c'est gelé vu tout
petit en culottes courtes mais il dit
des choses sur vous terrible il dit qu'à
l'époque vous combattiez médecin à nice
et que maintenant vous retrouver du côté
de marchiani
voilà une dizaine d'accords à vous
préférez vous voulez toujours est
réincarné en françois hollande s'il faut
choisir oui sinon j'ai fait c'est dans
cette question parce que tout bon
personne on veut choisir tout bon pour
la trouille quand même si la foule et
s'est tu me diras tu pourquoi être
réincarné c'est surtout ça louer alors
est ce que vous auriez plus de 10 on
vous donneriez plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ou
un vieux puisqu'il échappe sur des
chemins
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles
pour leur piquer leur sac à main qu'elle
sorte de la poste et leur pension 1 ou
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes le vieux
qui le vieux qui stoppe des jeunes avant
d'accord et je suis vieux déjà riche et
vous savez que c'est agréable
alors le mot le plus con pour vous en
amour c'est merci encore oui-oui ou
combien tu peux nous merci merci merci
merci mot stupide
un amour qui entend bien jouer est-ce
que vous préféreriez être coincés dans
un ascenseur avec bernard henri lévy ou
philippe sollers
[Musique]
vous voudriez être guillotiné ou pendus
guillotiné disons alors allons-y
guillotiné de la cause du bouquin à
parce que vous êtes dedans et gentilles
et c'est plus rapide sur un il faut
choisir je dis pas parce que oui c'est
plus propre d'une certaine manière oui
des pendus il fera encore d'une taille
respectable même sens il ya des
chevaliers sans tête pour me bouge pas
pour le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bouger je faisais n'aurions pas bougé
il amène chez yahoo et moustache n'a pas
aussi bien alors intervenu là je vous
préviens ce que vous préférez staline ou
hitler
la question c'est vraiment rude comme
questionnant c'est vrai mais c'est mort
ou vif
est ce que vous préférez votre carte
mère et s'était dit j'ai dit alors
attendez je sais j'ai averti celle
intervenue la ligne ça dépend des jours
grâce à l'ironie et entre mon père ou ma
mère vous préférez qui le fils senti est
ce que vous êtes déjà mangé du surgelé
dans un igloo non est-ce que vos
vêtements vous les préférez d'étain ray
tracing déchirait or bad est à priori
oui tu t'es vu toi tu t'es vue
oui
c'est un coup monté on ne dit pas les
fringues pas la famille josé et consorts
concentrez vous quel est d'après vous
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
nous sommes bien dans ses pas alors
maintenant à un dilemme c'est compliqué
un ami débarque chez vous à l'improviste
qu'est ce qui vous gêne le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf ou un godemiché mein kampf à
lui dans le larzac des faits sont en
même temps cinq ans à montredon du
larzac quand même attiré pas tu es
salaam aimerait vous parce que souvent
c'est ça va pas trop ce que tu imites là
une question que ces deux
amis ont pesé lundi sur comédie un
chauffeur vous êtes chauffeur routier
vous êtes obligés à la force de
fréquenter un vous êtes chauffeurs
routiers vous perdez le contrôle de
votre véhicule et une grande descente et
vous écrasé sur une maison ou sur une
autre
d'un côté il ya votre maison avec votre
femme et vos enfants et l'autre côté il
ya une école primaire
vous vous écrasez sur quoi c'est idiot
non c'est trop je sais pas qui est ce
qu'à monter c'est quand même et
fonctionnel lhc qui l'a inventé moi non
je saute avant comme ça j'ai pas
réfléchir ah oui d'accord mais on
rallume serge pugeault maintenant on va
faire une interview null null l'eau on
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon vous vous arbitraire janvier
stéphane d'accord
mauvaise idée que maintenant on m'avait
collé ça dans le cigare vous avez vous
appelé janvier stéphane pour toute la
vie ça marche bien alors roger vous êtes
prêts interview nul est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère ma
mère ah ouais vous dis carrément
j'adorais mon père mais vous je
préférais ma mère assez bien un petit
d'alger il est bien ce moment là dans le
sud c'est un peu comme ça non oui je le
sais très sud ça vous préfériez staline
ou hitler
salim staline pourquoi parce qu'il a tué
plus de gens j'apprends que je ne crois
pas qu'il détruit plus de gens là je
vais faire d'entremont sens de l'humour
j'espère que c'est monstrueux staline
non qu'on veut et allons dit il ya des
hommes qui a dévoyé le dépôt idéal qui
l'idéal communiste mais augmente nan je
sais que c'est la mode de 2,2 comparé
des communistes et les nazis et moi
c'est pas mon sentiment
d'accord oui c'est vrai qu'on compare on
a eu deux totalitarismes au 20e siècle
il ya eu l'hitlérisme et le stalinisme
et c'est vrai qu'on a on les compare
vous pensez que c'est pas comparable non
non non parce que je me suis fait
accrocher une fois dans une émission on
m'a dit mais comment osez vous dire que
vous êtes communiste était d'abord ne me
parlez pas sûr sont là sinon je paie
d'avril et comprendra non plus pourquoi
pas nazi 1 j'ai dit mais moi je vais
vous dire pourquoi pas ce que je peux
vous résumer l'idéal communiste
l'idéal communiste justice et partage
maintenant vous définissez moi l'idéal
nazis déplacement l'idéal nazis et
voyons si ça se confondrait qu'au début
l'idée communiste était une plus belle
idée que l'idée nationale socialiste je
trouve ans et de le reconnaître c'est
vrai alors est-ce que vous préféreriez
faire l'amour avec une fille très laide
ou un mec très beau il fit très laide
à hilla incorrigible quand même assez
vrai macho man est-ce que vous avez plus
de circoncis vous donner plus de
circonstances atténuantes à ada des
vieux qui se tape des jeunes ou à des
jeunes qui tapent sur des vieux plutôt
des jeunes qui se tape des vieux parce
que je trouve cette hausse in de
générosité extraordinaire
ouais non j'avais dit des jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux je sais bien mais
j'ai compris votre bouquin dans le
bouquin de roger dentelle effectivement
aurélie elle veut ses 70 ans un bain
plutôt pluvieux qui tapent sur des
jeunes est d'accord parce que sont bons
ils ont fini leur vision de départ est
bien roger évoqué d'un book est un
spécialiste
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore oui oui le plus con le but qu'on
sait c'est oui oui oui oui vous avez
compris va dire oui à roger alors la
bombe atomique arrive dans 5 minutes
vous faites quoi
bah je je je m'agenouille je priais des
cinq minutes qu'est-ce que je peux faire
toutes façons tu n'as pas le temps d'y
aller la celi rami c'est en fleur en
même temps tout seul ouais ou alors tout
seul
votre partenaire n'est pas très excité
vous lui demandez comment il s'appelle
vous lui faites un truc spécial où vous
vous cassez en claquant la porte
je crois que je pars sans claquer la
porte
bien élevé non parce que d'abord ça ne
change rien
ouais et on se diminue on est en bio
loin vous croyez pas toujours et cela
dit ça il ya 20 ans il ya vingt ans vous
auriez dit quoi le truc spécial eux ce
serait bien si vous étiez mort vous
voudriez être réincarné en quoi
attention on edouard balladur en giscard
d'estaing ou en pierre messmer empire
messmer en pierre messmer oui parce que
c'était à vosges et pas ses idées
politiques prêts c'est un héros il a une
belle gueule
et il a il a parlé net et puis là et
pendant la guerre il était que c'est
très très bien conduit ouais c'est vrai
on vous applaudir c'est la bonne tombe
pas tant dans le jingle vous le savez
saint pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
il est génial il bouge je voulais mon
pas moi je peux pas m'empêcher de
sourire en regardant lui bouge nous
aimons pâques à vous êtes joueur bien
alors l'interview nul donc chez les
questions les plus cons possible et les
réponses des deux tonnes possible on va
voir est-ce que ça c'est la question la
première question c'est la question qui
nous a été donnée par clotilde courau
qui désormais est une amie salut
clotilde est ce que par amour vous
embrasse riez cent fois de suite des
chaussettes sales genard amour oui mais
par amour évident
ben écoute et malgré tout l'amour que je
pourrais avoir pour une dame je ne
supporterais pas qu'elle soit salle donc
je ne pourrais pas embrasser non plus
ses chaussettes ça et vous vous le
feriez marion non parce que je sais que
claudie j'ai peur quelques coquilles de
coraux qui fasse ce genre de truc je
pourrais le faire si aussi là le
propriétaire des chaussettes est parti
depuis très longtemps et voilà qu un
assez beau cette fille chasse du fait de
jeu m'a dit vous posez la question c'est
un peu m'était cher par un petit peu
amer j'ai posé toutes les questions sauf
fétiche ou est-ce que vous préfériez
votre père votre mère je vais vous dire
très sincèrement ce propos tellement con
comme question saison passée avec très
con parce que moi je suis incapable de
répondre si bas si je vais pas me
répondre si si si il se trouve que ma
mère a été j'avais cinq ans quand à
l'étang est malade et donc j'ai toujours
vu une personne aux lits acquis à la fin
je faisais ces piqûre de morphine
ouais donc c'est vrai que la personne
vivante avec moi celui qui m'a vraiment
éduquer c'est mon père ouais et donc
finalement je pourrais dire que j'aimais
plus mon père que ma mère même si ça
paraît comme ça normal parce que c'était
une personne vivante alors que j'avais
en face de moi gamin une personne
uniquement malades qui était ma maman
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
alors il y à un grand débat vous savez
que anconina qui se déplacent pas tomber
si on préfère en général dire qu'on
préfère staline parce que l'idée
communiste ware est une idée généreuse
alors que les néo nazis ne l'est pas
c'est ce qu'on dira jamais revu et c'est
ce qu'on dit moi personnellement je
trouve sur deux monstres absolument
trigo
il ya aucune différence quoi selon les
aveux c'est vraiment laissé les frères
jumeaux mais ma préférence vraiment
hitler ou staline
moi je déteste plus hitler parce
qu'effectivement il cette idée d'
éradiquée de la surface de la terre des
gens parce qu'ils sont d'une religion
d'une origine les juifs les tziganes ou
les homosexuels mais staline
on peut lui en vouloir peut-être autant
parce qu'il a trahi une belle idée ouais
puis dans la tuque en même temps la tuer
sans est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en christophe dechavanne
nagui ou arthur
écoutez je pense lui quelques
difficultés actuellement donc je tiens
absolument à me réincarner en nagui oui
bon voilà assez gentil ces chrétiens ça
parce que certains parce que c'est mon
producteur
oui je sais que c'est le meilleur coach
que j'ai eu la garde côte tous sont
repartis avec des bêtises de monsieur
pierre je n'avais pas fait de prime time
depuis 86 ouais bon donc il me fallait
quelqu'un qui murray après il me donne
la pêche
comment animer n'y sont pas et ça a été
un coach absolument extraordinaire donc
c'est bien le dire en tous les cas chez
moi j'aimerais bien tagi quel est votre
punition préférez vous préférez être
passé mort du piquet ou griffer mordu à
mort du pain c'est piqué ou griffé à la
morsure dans l'amour ça existe oh il est
choqué 11
oui mais je dirais qu'il fasse le plus
mal castus sont horriblement mal et
pourtant c'est un temps il est chaud le
piège est ce que vous préféreriez
pendant dix ans c'est une vue de
l'esprit bien sûr pas de sexe ou pas
mangé pendant dix ans elle en disant pas
de sexe pas manger c'est une façon de
vous demander je préférais baiser au
bout fait en gros ben je pense quand
même que pour pour partir sur 10 ans au
bout comme ava creux on va forcément
crever c'est en revanche part il faut
quand même choisir de ne pas se taper
qui compte c'est le problème est
d'accord mais si vous êtes tout seul et
cheveux bien et à tête robinson crusoé
soit supportable et enfin vendredi
arriver là quand même on se console à
vous êtes d'accord
alors bon vous préféreriez être aveugle
et sourd ou amputé des bras et des
jambes non leur saison des cotonnades
etc et sur la contre attaque aveugle et
sourd ou alors amputé en bas et bat au
fond c'est quand même amputé des bras et
des jambes parce que aveugle et sourd
c'est quelque chose que je dirais vous
porter un slip un caleçon rien un slip
c'est très important c'est qu'on se
demande des fois à quoi ça sert services
publics laon le sima et oui voilà je
vous peut vous donner également des
mâles même marqué suisse très bonne
marque suisse quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux j'ai
horreur de me faire embrasser par les
animaux ah bon brazeau du tout jeune or
pas du tout c'est marrant c'est un peu
comme marion cotillard alors j'adore
j'adore me faire masser par qui on
voudra mais pas par les bords la
dernière question pierre bellemare
comment vendriez vous un vibromasseur
qui se recharge sur l'allume-cigare je
commencerai par dire
share and we l'objet que je vais vous
tendre doit absolument être utilisée sur
un parking et en aucun cas pendant la
marche des véhicules en effet à partir
du moment où vous avez branché saïgas le
vibromasseur que je vais maintenant vous
proposer tout est possible le nirvana
peut arriver et donc il est impossible
de jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps
est en train de doubler nos deux chaînes
de deux dash sur le dos bravo région
[Applaudissements]
fillon vous êtes en train de devenir une
star
il faut s'habituer on va vous poser des
questions on va poser des questions cons
parce que on va poser toutes les
questions un peu imbécile comme celle
posée donc on bouge dans les guignols ou
gens mais ce soir bien alors comment
vous êtes prêts à les leur poser une
première question qui est la question
dit clotilde courau c'est une question
qui a été inventé par clotilde courau
est ce que par amour vous embrasse
seriez sans fois de suite des
chaussettes sales
non non non et vous daniel o moi je
reste pas des questions si qu'on est
d'accord ça s'appelle l'interview nul ne
sait mais on peut dire nulles et quand
bien sûr alors maintenant la question la
question cubaine marie magnifique parce
qu'il a dit
la question en moins la question pierre
bellemare
comment vendriez vous un vibromasseur
qui se branche sur l'allume-cigare
frédéric diefenthal
moi j'en ai rien à [__] je fume pas
enfin la réponse de monsieur prévost je
suis marié je sais ça fait trois fois
bien elles sont allées à 100
est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner écoutez bien en lara fabian
en céline dion ou ans hélène ségara qui
pas lara fabian non non non mais je
sentais envie de dire ça je la vois bien
aller alors s'aligneront avis bien ces
lignes on à céline dion c'est bien ces
lignes d'eau quel est votre émission
préférée vous préférez être privé de
sexe ou privés de câlins privé de six
autres avec alain et 11e aucune de ces
pays mais vous savez où le raf est privé
de 6
privé de lara fabian privé de sexe se
priver de callac si vous préférez sexe
privé de sexe avec cléo cas là parce
qu'avec les câlins je me dis que ça
m'aide à cuba au bout d'un moment ça
peut le faire c'est vrai donc finalement
jamais de quel est le mot le plus con en
amour pour vous merci encore oui oui où
le rafale
oui à fabien non oui oui à qui vous
pensez frédéric diefenthal que pour
réussir la télé il faut être une ordure
un pourri ou un [__] points
je crois qu'avec un peu des trois ça
peut marcher vous avez la télé il a
répondu c'est pas réussi moi on va
terminer sur une question de culture
politique l'esprit ni citer les quatre
prétendants de l'opposition pour la
mairie de paris à tous porthos et aramis
et l'autre c'est comment des gens là
c'est dur c'est dur ça quels sont les
1004 prétendants balladur oui très bien
je suis soufflé pas souffle pas m'at on
ne souffle pas
du rugby
des canyons faut trois ans qui viennent
dire au cas c'est vraiment toi
il a dit quelque chose mais coûte mais
quand daniel prévost ô vous les avez
vous les connaissez pas non je connais
ça n'a aucune importance je sais
simplement pour montrer que finalement
tout le monde s'en fout ce truc là à
dire que la presse en parle toute la
journée sa télé entend toute la journée
la radio toute la journée et tout le
monde s'en fout la preuve j'avais même
pas super important de le savoir faire
et c'est moi aussi on pourrait répondre
livier c'est trop dit ou pas assez gains
sega sega oui tiberi tiberi oui balladur
mais pour l'opposition le dialogue en a
quatre mais la position
séguin à la fia
chaque style encore plus étonné que
quand il conduit son taxi dans le film
c'est du sauvage découvre sa télévision
de l'an 2007 3e minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors l'interview nul vous allez
voir c'est très très con c'est normal ça
s'appelle comme ça dans le chinon ça
s'appellerait pas l'interview nul voila
est-ce que vous préfériez d'hitler ou
staline gens préfèrent aucun mais on
compare pas récupéré choisir je choisis
a certainement pas hitler d'accord
aujourd'hui à manama
on attend maintenant la dialectique de
14 ans et déjà dans le coup va t'en sers
de ce lien il est au courant alors tiens
voilà
imaginez que vous croyez la
réincarnation vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en giscard balladur ou
raymond barre terry a maintenant mais
c'est à vous êtes amis de tiberi je
préfère peut être un quart à non non je
vais pas me répondre ça scénario composé
de giscard giscard balladur ou bar voilà
c'est un jeu là c'est moi parce que
balladur parce que moi je ferais rire
les gens ah oui d'accord ça passe
vous avez été bien est-ce que vous
donnez plus de circonstances atténuantes
écoutez bien les compliquée celle là à à
des vieux qui se tape des jeunes ou à
des jeunes qui tapent sur des vieux et
des jeunes qui tapent sur des vieux way
où ils ont plus de 30 ans a tenu en nord
- à moins de 5 ans à sète et niort ah
ouais non c'est moi qui a renversé la
question accord donc il vaut mieux être
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes car
jeunes qui tapent sur un vieux d'accord
entre pas de sexe et pas mangé pendant
dix ans vous choisiriez quoi compliquer
compliqué le camarade pas de sexe parce
que si vous mangez pas pendant dix ans
toute manière il y aura pas de sexe très
bien bien dialectique dialectique
toujours imaginer qu'on soit aux sports
d'hiver tous les deux dans un chalet
bloqués par la neige
moi je meurs de faim on n'a plus rien à
manger je meurs de faim et vous vous
avec moi à manger vous commencez par
quoi le cerveau le crb on dirait pas
pourquoi pour moi non le cerveau le
cerveau alors j'étais obligée de partir
sur une île déserte alain krivine vous
préféreriez partir avec un mec très beau
une fille très laide avec très beau une
fille très loin c'est pour y rester de
l'ombre une fille très laide
ah oui quand même vous n'êtes pas du
tout cas là tout le sel du tout dit mais
c'est pas une injure du tout du tout
pour moi dakar non mais pour moi non
plus la salle alors un ami débarque à
l'improviste chez vous ce qui vous
ferait le plus au monde qui découvre sur
l'étape de nuit
le livre de claire chazal ou un
godemichet
il y en a un qui est un outil de plaisir
paraît-il
oui le livre et l'autre qui est bon
enfin bref donc oui non plus plutôt le
livre de claire chazal vous préfériez
qui voit le livre de claire chazal que
nkunda qui voit plutôt le godemichet si
vous avez bon coeur qu'est-ce que vous
échangeriez votre paralysie générale
vous serez paralyser toute votre vie
pour qu'ils aient plus de famine en
ethiopie je dirais non parce que c'est
le resterez mensonger ouais donc j'ai là
non je me battrais pour qu'il y ait plus
de familles en ethiopie pour ça faut pas
dire de l île paralysée toute votre
frère il faut pas être paralytique pour
empêcher la famine fait mal a du sens le
mec a discuté avec ses copains des
années
[Musique]
q
bon évidemment vous n'avez pas bougé
pendant le jingle et je vous en félicite
vous savez que c'est la chose la plus
importante pour moi dans cette émission
donc c'est pas les questions nul de
d'habitude j'ai bossé cet été moi j'ai
pas j'ai bossé jamais préparé des
nouvelles halles à ce que je vous ai vu
dans les journaux en vacances bannon cdd
cdi
ce qu'il faut c'est plus mais maintenant
j'ai vraiment bossé parce qu'avant je
vous disais vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère ou hitler ou staline ça pas
du tout c'est l'extrait qu'on vient de
voir
oui aurait inspiré la question s'il
n'avait pas déjà trouvé une vraie
différence entre votre coupe de cheveux
votre coiffure dans l'extrait convient
de voir est aujourd'hui la première
question que je suis une femme vous vous
laver les cheveux tous les combien c'est
tous les jours
adacore voilà je fais maintenant tous
les jours toujours avant j'étais
raplapla affichée par les ciel et
c'était un peu gras mouillé la wii sur
l'extrait c'est normal
ah ouais vous avez en transpire sur
scène oui mais voilà vous donne rarement
oui franchement je fais un compliment en
forme
ah oui je vous ai rarement vu aussi chic
aussi voici prof
ainsi m disons qu il tient très bien le
succès vous va bien
alors est ce que vous préférez attention
c'est assez compliqué est ce que vous
préférez un président de la république
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou pas d'élection du tout pas
d'élections dites pas d'élection du tout
donc c'est pour la dictature à ce moment
là complètement ça reviendra au m c'est
pourtant ce concours comme midi
quelle différence y at-il entre frédéric
françois et françois valéry après les
durs ça je reconnais qu il faut vraiment
il faut vraiment des gens mois d'été
ils sont toujours là alors alors qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez avoir année
supplémentaire un oeil supplémentaires
un doigt un sexe et si c'était un chèque
supplémentaire lequel le sexe de mon
amant gaza ouais bonne réponse
et comme les escargots comme ça pour s
ils sont pas chier des escargots vins
une idée même boîte tu vois le bras
d'honneur confrères gonzesses on aura un
sexe de femme pas loin juste là internet
y est satisfait ben tu vois je baise
michel et fring vendre de la drogue la
sortie des écoles si la survie de vos
enfants dépendent et c'est idiot sept
villages en studio elle est monstrueuse
s'appelle interview c'est le choix de
sophie s'associer exactement soit donc
là c'est au bon niveau c'est que je suis
mais loin de tout ça moi je prends un
passeport et je me casse loin de ce
monde pourri non mais tu peux te dire
évidemment tu peux pas de barre et la
question c'est que j'ai pas d'argent je
peux d'accord c'est nul je peux si vous
en aviez le pouvoir ou mettriez vous
parie sur la carte de france à paris
appareil à vous les services il pleut
toujours aussi certainement cela qui en
panne on sait bien c'est super moi je
crois j'ai passé un moment merveilleux
des contes tu as du temps fou c'est à
toi qui a réussi si je reprends la même
la fin de la conversation c'est vrai que
10 fait beau bon et compte en date
c'est un peu comme ce qu'on a eu c'est
pourtant elle était pour nous d'essayer
de faire de la concurrence à tf1 la
ménagère choix quand la tient à la gorge
chez lui
c'est fait
c'est quoi ça vous êtes devenu macho
dans les bacs maman pas du tout match la
matinée a annoncé sa non c'est
simplement
mais qu'est ce que ça va être des coûts
la différence entre hétéros et m'a
toujours pas ba a été rossé un match
sympa et un mathieu sa météo qu'on bon
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi comme objet moi
partageons bien elle vibre commence à
vibrer bon bien des questions
et pour vous l'image de l'image la plus
triste une valve à sa fenêtre un chien
perdu sur une autoroute ou un dimanche
devant la télé une veuve à sa fenêtre
non triste c'est finalement je vends le
oui mais tu peux dormir donc t'oublie
c'est fait pour ça la cave à sa fenêtre
howe est terrible ça de perdre son mari
et d'avoir pas de fenêtre ça sera encore
il ya des lieux qui a été chez lapeyre
avant là une fenêtre c'est vrai qu'elle
peut regarder la vie et se dire que
c'est possible de sauter
j'en arrive d'aller parler de design
bernstein qui va arriver et dans lautrec
le merveilleux film de roger planchon il
ya cette phrase merveilleuse ou 4 la
fille se fait découper en tranches et
tout est dit tu veux médecins en images
lui dit son frère et lui dit non pas de
pathétique en peinture la cruauté
tranquille du quotidien suffit voilà la
veuve à sa fenêtre merci jean marie
bigard à la bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien donc on va vers l'inter du nul de
toute façon est ce que vous connaissez
clotilde courau clotilde courau il ya
une question maintenant qui s'appelle la
question de clotilde courau et je vous
la pose mais entendu est-ce que vous
embrasse seriez par amour
cent fois une paire de chaussettes sales
de dany boon non vous le feriez pas à
vous ça non non non vous n'êtes pas
comme côté de pau non est ce que vous
préférez votre père ou votre mère c'est
l'interview du linge c'est ce que tu
aimerais mieux rouler une pelle à ta
mère ou couché avec ton père vous pouvez
améliorer la question et de les deux
d'accord je suis un page accepte les
deux
est-ce que vous accorde riez plus de
circonstances atténuantes à un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles mais pourquoi
faudrait-il qu'ils les circonstances
atténuantes bas parce que un vieux qui
se tape des petites
oui ça vous gêne pas voulait me garder
oui c'est vrai qu'ils se taper une
petite jeune ou un jeune rat sur les
vieilles attend hors de question qu'un
jeune table sur une vieille vous
préférez les vieux qui se tape des
jeunes
si elles sont consentantes oui c'est
vrai j'aurais pas dû vous poser cette
question est-ce que vous préfériez faire
l'amour avec un mec très laid ou une
fille très belle fille très belle puis
très bien est ce que votre chien est ce
que pour ans et un ami qui rentre chez
vous la nuit par votre chambre et vous
dire un copain ou pas du tout est ce que
vous auriez plus honte qu'ils trouvent
sur votre table de chevet le livre de
claire chazal ou un godemiché un
godemichet ça vous ferait plus sombre
que le livre de claire serait enfin ont
tassé
un sentiment qu'est ce que j'en ai à
[__]
ni l'un ni l'autre enfin à [__] moi tu
les doigts rôle et vous quel est votre
punition préféré être à ces mordus ou
pique et pince mardi la mort du sage et
vous êtes immédiatement des ouais mais
on note là c'est tout et là tout est
noté tout est enregistré sur bande
est-ce que alors maintenant autres
sérieusement dany boon
il est une panne sexuelle est une
hypothèse évidemment les coins d'une
panne sexuelle
peut-être à besançon là en ce moment à
plein les fatiguer peut-être alors il ya
une panne sexuelle un jour ça
m'étonnerait avec vous qu'on puisse
avoir des pannes sexuelles mais c'est un
jeu vous lui demander comment elle
s'appelle première solution vous lui
faites un truc à vous votre truc à vous
vous vous cassez en claquant la porte
moi j'y fais un truc à moi premier
ensuite je lui demande comment elle
s'appelle et finalement je m'en vais
avec leurs bras de bonnes réponses
alors imaginez c'est toujours une
supposition
vous disparaissez oui dany aussi mais
bon on attendait maintenant il disparaît
s'il meurt c'est pas un truc c'est inner
c'est pas humain
c'est la partie un peu solennel de
l'hémicycle et c'est à partir tout peu
hard
alors bon vous mourrez tous les deux
est-ce que vous préféreriez que noël
soit confiée à julien courbet a laissé
tomber la grèce élevée par julien
courbet le petit bataille et fontaine
bon c'est violent aussi un des
animateurs julien courbet bataille et
fontaine où christophe dechavanne rang
de chavannes un oued de chavannes
dechavanne
si les tournées lycos à nu ce jour des
gosses ouais si vous deviez mourir dans
un crash d'avion et en rendez vous prévu
comme ça voilà sachant que tes gosses
sont élevés par julien comblât dernières
paroles avant de décéder on mourait dans
un crash d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
préféreriez un avion d'air france
d'egyptair ou de la varig à cette
interview nul mais regardez pas comme ça
le principe de ce qu'est ce que vous
avez passé que j'ai une peur terrible un
avion pour la france
pour la famille allait à gonesse abbas
est pas
alors
michal question est-ce que vous
préféreriez être incarné ans marguerite
duras ou marilyn monroe ou julien
courbet marguerite duras ah bon c'est
son côté intello ça les cantons et
marilyn monroe on peut encore apprendre
mais quand on fait du race on peut
jamais devenir mari maintenant quand
même une certaine façon elle a été
mariée monroe ah non là on n'a pas vu ça
nous a bien échapper la façon dont on
connecte et maryline personne n'a
remarqué c'est incroyable qu'elle me
détestez vous prononcer un parcours des
prononcer le mot qui vous n'arrivez pas
à prononcer quelques sessions rendent
son pied s'il vous plaît pas ce nom vous
dit comment
avoir du plaisir hu
[Musique]
il a bougé nantes où on était parfait et
toi qui hérite était exemplaire avec moi
je suis obligée de l'exemple exemplaires
est ce que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère je préfère les deux j'ai pas
de choix c'est dur à sa non venue j'ai
dit que c'est les questions vont ça oui
mais il n'y a pas de choix
elle suit c'est une question qu'on l'a
mais j'en étais sûr qu est ce que vous
préférez hitler ou staline dit pas les
idiots non alors c'est le coude du clos
la peste ou le choléra ça mais je peux
pas choisir non plus c'est aussi
important vous les mettez au même niveau
je déteste les deux voies là non parce
que c'est qu'en france il ya toujours
des gens qui nous explique que staline
c'est mieux qu hitler
je ne partais pas de ce principe là
n'ont bien sûr pas mal vous devez partir
sur une île déserte
c'est un jeu de l'esprit un vous préféré
partir avec des tapis ou dominique
strauss kahn
alors il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
feu y a pas photo dominique strauss kahn
dont les cassettes est un ami oui
j'assume cette amitié complètement ça
c'est un bon côté vous avez les
socialistes vous c'est à dire que les
mecs peuvent faire les pires trucs vous
les soutenez toujours c'est votre côté
me taire mon ami non c'est mon ami et je
suivais pas à juger tel ou tel chose
c'est mon ami dont vous partez avec
dominique strauss kahn c'est jospin est
mon ami c'est mon ami d'accord voilà oui
bien sûr il est sympa ils vont dire plus
à thierry après ce serait il se donne du
mal là pour avoir l'air sympa là il a
fait douze pages dans gala j'aime bien
quand vous regardez comme ça
il a celle à faire je ne sais pas si tu
as le regarde de claude allègre quand
ils me regardent et qu'ils oublient
c'est comme ça quand tu lui dis une
question qui l'emmerdé y regarde la
haute question qu'on vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien tous les jours
un an presque travaux bien parce que tu
le vaux bien
est ce que vous préférez un président de
la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout pas d'élection du tout vous arrêtez
d'être démocratique à un moment quand ça
vous arrange plus vous arrêter d'être
démocrate
vous me posez une question humour est
d'accord moi ça me rappelle en algérie
quand même et joue paume quand le christ
a failli gagner les élections en algérie
on arrêter le processus est posé vous me
posez une question je vous répondrai que
sa mère n'était bien est-ce que ça
discours mr dsk me dire qu'ils aient
bataille qui est fontaine
je vous connaissais bataille et fontaine
je connais un joueur de foot qui
s'appelle fonta juste fontaine bien sûr
que c'est chaud ses rentes 58 la suède
vous connaissez pas bataille et fontaine
non vous pouvez pas me dire que les
batailles qui est fontaine non sarah est
ce que pouvait me dire que les batailles
qui est fontaine
ce sont des comiques non ce sont des
présentations commis que d'une certaine
façon une campagne sans présentateur sur
tf1 y'a pas photo les batailles qui est
fontaine y en a un qui est grand mais
rien qu'un peu plus petit un peu plus
gros le cas les batailles de calais
fontaine alors je crois que pascal c'est
le grand pascal quai n'essayez pas de
m'embrouiller et fontaine
[Musique]
sa fille linda cardiaque
non mais ça c'est une question interne
de part de marché tous les lundis soir
catherine me dit que vous avez raison
vous savez que les batailles qui est
fontaine alors claude allègre est ce que
vous aimeriez avoir un et supplémentaire
ni suppléments des supplémentaires
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires
j'aimerais avoir un oeil supplémentaire
derrière à la peur de te remettre il
arrivé en même temps est-ce que vous
préférez une femme n'aime pas tellement
faire l'amour
nick est fidèle ou une femme qui adore
faire l'amour mais qui était infidèle la
deuxième bien sûr ah ouais c'est bien là
je pense pas que l'attesterait sur
allègre bel et bien c'est avec déception
la question c'est vraiment une bonne
idée donc vous préférez une femme qui
aime faire l'amour et au risque qu'elle
soit infidèle
oui au risque et haut risque et vous
vous préférez un garçon qui sait
peut-être parce que vous pouvez espérer
si vous avez sur la combler qu'elles
soient pas quand même faire à gaz ou à
la merci de l'explication et vous vous
préférez un garçon qui sait pas très
bien faire l'amour mais qui est très
fidèle ou un garçon qui fait
merveilleusement l'amour un italien
génial et tout mais qui en même temps
voilà il court partout mais les italiens
sont souvent infidèles
quand vous apprenez votre parti est même
choix choix et c'est que la france
entière se demande quel est votre numéro
de portable ça relish taddert a pas
bougé 1
elle est géniale pour une bourse c'est
dur
mignonne comme tout est bouché henry il
vient le moment où il va pouvoir se
barrer bien alors intervenu lui averti
sur des questions très con donc vous
pouvez répondre très connement comme
comme avons quoi qu'ils jugent comme
avant d'accord vous préférez votre père
votre mère ma mère par la force des
choses vous préférez hitler ou staline
dans la famille on n'a pas vraiment
apprécié hitler staline règles connues
pas vous dire ouais alors vous partez
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial c'est
un classique ça vous préféré partir
alors avec sarkozy que vous avez appelé
le lapin duracell c'est bien couvert je
vous félicite c'est bien trouvé le lapin
duracell
quand vous partez avec sarkozy
douste-blazy ou françois hollande dans
un vaisseau spatial oui pendant trois
ans
non moi je parte pas vous êtes obligés
de partir obligé de barrer douste-blazy
sarkozy ou françois hollande
abitbol à nous rejoindre au long de ces
jeunes avec hollande
je connais pas ouais ouais faut pas se
tromper
est ce que vous trouvez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites un vieux qui se tape
des pics ou un jeune qui tape sur les
vieilles à vos premiers 1 bah oui ça le
droit un au revoir mais si vous préférez
un président d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout c'est ça le sport est universel
ouais ouais si vous ça ne peut pas
arriver si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop vous seriez quoi comme objet
aaa tout en sachant que nous l'aurait
dans le cul
vous seriez quoique j'ai pas qu'est ce
qu'on vend des sex shops on veut encore
dans les seiches iphone répondre
williams nous étendons dans un sex-shop
vous êtes quoi pas de langue de bois
il n'y a pas de langue de bois et
fonctionne avec et sans que j'avoue très
long mais très sincèrement avoir des
godemichés des films je sais pas ce
qu'on vendre les actions seraient
godemiché donc je me vois pas et revient
ce que tu disais voilà un film à moi
tout seul donc ça doit forcément l'autre
l'autre faire bryan michaud vous
préférez une femme
alors ça c'est très important vous
préférez une famille une épouse une
maîtresse qui baisent mal etc et fidèle
winky baisse bien mais qu'un infidèle
c'est terrible c'est terrible mais c'est
que des questions comment je dois faire
la première à oui mais si vous préférez
une femme qui bosse mâles qui m'écrit
fidèles ouais c'est bizarre c'est pas du
tout comme tu préfères quoi toi il peut
aller ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas moi
qu'on pose la question moi j'ai droit de
faire ce que je veux henry vous préférez
quoi vous pourquoi moi qui passe mal et
qu'ils aiment celle qui bossent bien
mais qu'elle a fidèlement et je suis
casé je sais pas vous poser la question
elle préfère un mec qui bosse bien mais
qu'un infidèle
le salvador est vite dupont s'est alors
attention william abitbol vous vous
concentrez s'il vous plaît vous
passeriez plus volontiers la nuit avec
anne sinclair à regarder des cassettes
c'est pas moi vu libre oui en ce moment
là du temps avec anne sinclair lors
sinclair ou bottes sinclair lors
sinclair l'ours en clair quant au cvc
pour chaque pays et que l'élan sinclair
bages et canal+
ouais vous seriez plus surpris si on
vous trouvez au lit avec un mec avec
deux filles et un mec
ah oui ça bouge ce serait plus choquant
pour vous bon sang je serai sur moi
surprise
[Musique]
c'est bien à anna ne bouge pas par le
jingle vous non plus rihanna sait bien
les filles bien alors attention c'est
compliqué c'est l'interview c'est la
main que vous préférez votre père votre
mère c'est nul j'avais versé nul
ouais mais je vous réponds les deux mon
général ça dépend des la nuit ma mère
qui est morte et le jour mon père qui
est en vie voilà vous préférez hitler ou
staline staline quand même pourquoi
parce qu'il a tué plus de gens non non
pour une eau non pour une vraie règle la
différence si vous voulez c'est que le
communisme est un rêve dramatiquement
avorter le nazisme n'a jamais eu une
part de rêve commise le communisme vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est un idéal des
voiliers ouais le nazisme n'épargnèrent
[Applaudissements]
le mot le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore
oui oui je trouve que lewis est plus
ambivalent
alors vous préféreriez mourir comme john
lennon qui a été abattu par un coup de
revolver comme otis redding qui est mort
dans une chute dans un accident d'avion
un crash comme janis joplin qui est
morte d'une overdose ou comme bones
scott le chanteur décide ici qu'est il
s'est étouffé dans son vomi assas plus
originales comme mes bonnes scott
la prochaine fois on verra mac avec des
petites cornes comme lycées d'ici et
puis un short comme ambition si vous
vous préféreriez mourir tout de suite et
aller au paradis ou vivre encore 30 ans
et leur d'enfer en vivre encore 30 ans
et aller en enfer ça comme je crois
venir paradinha l'anc avait regagné les
transports vous vous laver les cheveux
tous les combien comme vous plus trois
fois par semaine pareil est ce que vous
préférez un président d'extrême droite
élu au suffrage universel ou pas
d'élection du tout pas d'élection du
tout ah ouais vous arrêtez de me
démontrer le président d'extrême droite
et du suffrage universel supprimera
l'élection au coup d'après ouais donc à
tout prendre c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec hitler c'est quand même ce qu'ils
savent c'est vrai kit l'air alors acquis
confieriez-vous plus facilement vos
enfants si vous disparaissez sied à
maxime gremetz noël mamère ou jean louis
debré au avec maxime dereymez je suis
sûr qu'ils iraient à l'école et qu'ils
auraient de bonnes notes
si jamais vous retourner vers le
communisme quand même alors imaginez
c'est une vue de l'esprit
vous rentrez chez vous vous trouvez
votre femme au lit avec rocco siffredi
c'est un jeu de l'esprit vous restez en
participant vous restez en boudant où
vous restez en vous pendant je médite
mehdi terme élite vous partez pas à
jamais aucune situation voyait même à
votre question je pars pas anodine
on va maintenant passer à l'interview
nul en ne bouge pas pendant le dîner
voilà les révolutionnaires risque c'est
bien
alors soyez concentré jean claude
gayssot est ce que vous préférez sont
intervenus là je vous avertis et vous
allez voir c'est très nul les questions
est ce que vous préférez votre père
votre mère
difficile je suis partagé
peut-être ma mère c'est dur votre père
votre mère alors j'aimerais pas comme
lacoste drôlement merde
bah oui quoi je dirais qui tu répondes
j'ai beau tourner à bergman
j'adore quand il dit qu'il veut répondre
avec elle sans réponse est non il y en a
une âme je vais répondre plus facilement
vous préférez staline hitler et pensions
si vous à dire cinq ans
ok ça c'est nouveau non je dis si les
communistes disait staline quand même
d'être le premier communiste que je vois
répondants firmin pas je suis en bas
mais je vous assure c'est tout ça tout
ce qu'on nous a mis à part peut-être
participer en apnée ans et nous mêmes
peut être prêté à ce qu'on nous colle
cette idée qu'on était qu'on voulait
faire comme la bac en poupe qu'on était
porteur de ces crimes qu'ils ont commis
et tout ça peut-être là dans notre façon
d'être de les défendre parce qu'il y
avait le méchant loup américain et qu'il
fallait tout ça ça a dû exister
d'ailleurs y'a pas que y'a pas que les
communistes
bref en tout cas par cas je peux vous
dire que le communisme tel que nous le
concevons aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir
n'est bien sûr avec khider l'a combattu
à mieux parti des fusillés
c'est les communistes bon à partir de 41
ans jean-claude web est là on attend
d'elle tout cas les biens dit penser a
dit à une partie difficile et j'étais
obligée de vous parler du pacte
germano-soviétique oui les et de
passionnés c'est pas terrible pacte
germano-soviétique que l'epu est compris
à ce moment là le soutenir je ne suis
pas fier de cela je vous le dis alors à
qui trouvez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des jeunes moins jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux un vieux qui se
tape des jeunes comme votre femme est là
un levier qui se tape déjà plus de cinq
ans en s'atténuant why we un ami
débarque chez vous la nuit à
l'improviste il rentre il s'approche de
la table de nuit
vous dormez votre femme dort qu'est-ce
qui vous gênerait le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur la table de chevet un
godemichet ou mein kampf
mike aof alors attention jean claude
gayssot est ce que vous accepteriez de
mourir comme ça subitement là maintenant
si cela devait éradiquer pour toujours
la pauvreté sur la terre si ça devait
oui oui mais comme je suis fischer comme
jeudi la journée serge esprits sur vous
n'y aura plus jamais de peau vous allez
mourir n'y aura plus jamais de pauvres
sur la terre oui oui peut-être oui eh
ben c'est possible aujourd'hui question
compliquée on est tous les deux dans un
chalet c'est l'hiver on est sous la
neige
on a bouffé moi je meurs de froid
tellement j'ai rien à manger tellement
il fait froid et pour survivre est
obligé de me manger vous commencez par
quelles parties de mon corps j'élimine
tout ce qui risque d'amener la loterie
da comment s'appellent les prions de la
dalle est friand vous fait pas les
viscères jeune âge que les muscles
je touche pas tu as colonne vertébrale
très hâte à moi les attend cerveau marc
collat ca vaut mieux pas le bon j'ai un
cerveau deux monarchistes vous allez
vous en plus les aînés bien alors
attention à la serre votre entourage m'a
demandé de pas vous parler de vos
origines turques un ancien des sas il
défriche de balladur je me souviens plus
gêné d'être surpris par jacob donc au
lit avec deux filles ou un mec plus
gênés avec des filles avec un mec ce
noble et parce qu'un mec c'est pas
possible
ah ouais avec la carrure à bouliac vous
savez pas ce que c'est comme ça 3
pourquoi
bien dernière question la plus contre
tout si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop vous seriez quoi vous savez ce
que c'est qu'une branlette
oui c'est vrai une branlette oui c'est
la partie médiane de la canne à pêche
annoncer sa liste pourquoi vous dans une
canne à pêche et la partie médiane
s'appelle de la branlette les personnes
je le dire parce qu'il parle comme gros
lot à fait d'accord dont vous soyez une
branlette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous partez sur une île déserte
vous préférez une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau je préfère une fille puis
même la ddt
ah ouais ah oui d'accord c'est un vrai
terreau jean marie messier est un vrai
terreau mesdames et sa dilatation
circonstances atténuantes vous donner le
plus de circonstances atténuantes un
vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles un
vieux qui samedi petit vous préparer
pour hollywood la non mais l'autre bien
alors un ami arrive chez vous à
l'improviste en pleine nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus ce
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
c'est que j'ai fait à balladur salle
imaginé et loire un ami arrive à
l'improviste chez vous sur la table de
nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus bête
le plus qui trouve mein kampf ou un
godemiché mein kampf mannequin quoi
balladur mein kampf aussi mais c'est ce
que c'est qu'un god croyable bien sûr
qu'il sera turquie dans tout ce jeu
alors ok puis à me lâcher un petit c'est
lamentable bien alors est-ce que vous
échangeriez une paralysie générale si
vous êtes tétraplégique pour le restant
de vos jours contre la faim de la famine
au bangladesh
le chip and hate
je dis oui si je suis honnête on sait
bien que non est ce que vous êtes un
ambitieux qui a ramé ou un opportuniste
qui a eu de la chance j'ai un ambitieux
que la chance à bonn répond on part en
vacances tous les deux dans la montagne
il fait très froid il ya beaucoup de
ménage à trois mètres de neige on peut
pas aller faire les courses je meurs
vous n'avez plus rien à manger vous me
manger vous commencez par quoi partie
bien dodues le gros cube d'accor dans
groupe jean marie messier veut bouffer
le pied de redescendre crise par le haut
si vous le dire dans les connaissent le
curé qu'est ce que tu veux c 501 et ça
se sent sur dernière question jean marie
mais si vous vous laver les cheveux tous
les combien toujours tous les deux jours
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bougé merde à cause de toi aussi
les vosgiens est ce que vous préférez
votre père ou votre mère j'ai averti
c'est pas possible je pars actions
d'intérêt je peux pas je vois
monseigneur di falco qui attend là-bas
rassurez vous monseigneur cette
interview on l'a fait à samuel le bihan
donc vous y avez échappé defacto alors
plus simple lorsque préféré staline ou
hitler
j'ai envie de dire staline mais c'est
pourquoi il a tué plus de gens quittent
l'air voilà
et puis c'est un peu plus plus méconnu
c'est un peu moins proche parent est
d'accord oui les gens seront informés du
goulag des queues de suite c'est
vraiment alors ça c'est déjà plus simple
vous êtes trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial est ce que vous préférez partir
avec kad et o ù bataille et fontaine
trop tu dis ce que tu veux on n'en
voudra pas ce que tu as aimé venir à
voir le film promotionnel un peu plus
j'ai déjà vu leurs émissions et voilà ça
ne s'est pas rendu aux cadets aux
gentils bonne bourre les mecs on n'est
pas contre nous ah non pas du tout je
souhaite en effet battu les fourneaux
bien alors vous partez couple veut
partir c'est niet
elle me passe la caisse maladie soit
votre émission lundi sur le fond sa
quéquette c'est pas trop service public
ça quand même hein alors [__] vous
partez sur une île déserte
si vous partez sur une île déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou une fille très laide
filtrer l'inde
vous n'êtes pas [__] du tout vos mais
pas du tout ouais
désolé mais voilà j'ai jamais vu ça
quand même préféré préfet mais je
préfère une fille très lettre qu'un mec
très beau avec sasson au bout deux jours
je trouve ça très belle donc
il est tout petit j'ai oublié de dire
y'a pas on peut pas se planquer 1
est-ce que vous accordez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles c'est quel âge
les petites 14 ans et 14 ans est rude
je préfère celui qui tape les billets
vous rappelle des bons souvenirs
votre punition préféré c'est être peint
ces mordus ou piquer amants du j'aime
bien le mot le plus quand en amour c'est
merci encore où
oui oui ça n'est pas dans quel n'en est
rien
merci ctreq merci c'est plus de 60 ans
qu'on n'a rien foutu
merci alors samuel si vous aviez un
perroquet mais j'évite un perroquet
voulu apprendriez quoi comme phrase tu à
fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco
j'avais averti jeudi que son aile
dernière bien si utiles les perroquets
ah oui ça c'est terrible ça vous trouvez
votre fiancée au lit avec depardieu
ça c'est chiant question qu'est ce que
vous faites
ryle éclate vous restez
qu'est ce que vous faites vous restez
vient vous mettez au lit avec eux et je
regarde vous regardez oui vous gifle et
votre fiancée vous boudez vous tuer vous
parler boulot 6e de miss depardieu vous
savez qu'on ne bouge pas pour le jingle
de c
comment le sait on ne bouge pas pendant
le vigueur bien c'est l'interview nul
oui vous préférez steyn ou hitler ni
l'un ni l'autre je déteste le stalinisme
et l'hitlérisme et le fascisme c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut combattre toute
sa vie préféré à l'indolence jean paul
belmondo et ben écoutez je ne dis pas
devant son fils j'adore alain delon même
si on pense pas tout à fait la même
chose et la première fois que j'ai vu
c'était pour les 10 ans tf1 75 à la tour
eiffel c'est mon rosicky me l'a présenté
mais tomber dans les bras et il m'a dit
tu sais je t'aime bien
et depuis on est devenus amis alors oui
et ont tellement d'eau je le connais
mais j'ai pas les mêmes liens qu avec
alain delon
oui des gens qui aiment votre père
heureusement bien vous partez trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial président oui
préféré partir avec etienne mougeotte
marc tessier patron de france
télévisions où pierre lescure sophie
marceau vous croisez un extraterrestre à
matin d'aller acheter des cigarettes
extra terreste vous dit vous êtes qui
vous et vous connais évidemment vous ne
répondez quoi je suis avec bourges
ah ouais il suffit de penser que les
extraterrestres ce n'est pas celle que
peu d'importance n'hésite pas je suis un
terrien passion il passe son chemin et
moi le mien c'est que je suis un humain
je suis intérieur brice hervé bourmaud
n'est bâti vous êtes fuir les bouquins
d'accord bien avec la tiens ça c'est un
email de jim pour envoyer des emails
pour des questions ça s'est compliqué
avec quel pays la france a la plus
grande frontière
si j'étais vache je dirais avec la
belgique mais c'est le cas justement
j'en sais rien
le brésil bravo à cause de la guyane par
les accords
tout à fait vous voyez je suis nul si
vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi je ne crois que je ne
serai jamais en vente dans un sex shop
moi parce que je ne suis pas
suffisamment attire
quel est le sport le plus combo le
football américain
aulas mais voilà amérique on va pas vous
défendez plus mon équipe de football
américain
alors expliquez vous restez bien assis
très sexy comme le sport les uniformes
sont fantastiques
c'est devenu un petit peu plus que
maintenant parce qu'il ya trop de
publicité et lv1 30 ans c'était quelque
chose d'extraordinaire
le c'est comme le sport le foot ici en
europe des cons commercialisons une
paire son mystère
alors si vous deviez partir sur une île
déserte ou partiriez avec un mec très
beau une fille très laide milani le
niveau bas tant que c'est pas attiré par
les hommes et je n'aime pas les filles
moches mais non mais une qui s'appelle
mia si tu nous regardes nina me nadji
moi chaque fois qu'un acteur ou
quelqu'un qui veut partir avec une fille
mais je suis d'accord
voilà ce que samuel le bihan par exemple
il disait moi je préfère partir avec une
film j'ai reçu d'accord elle quand elle
a vu samuel le bihan va bien si vous
deviez mourir présidence de l'accident
d'avion vous préféreriez que ce soit air
france va rigoler giltaire ça mais
strictement égal si je dois mourir peu
importe la compagnie avant l'état
nationaliste vous préfériez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion comme
john lennon d'un shot comme bones scott
le chanteur décide ici que s'est étouffé
dans son vomi nous comme janis joplin
qui est morte d'une overdose
non rires dans son vomi dans certaines
la tour d'argent non il ya longtemps que
j'ai pu à la tour d'argent c'est un
bordel là
le canard au sang était pas mal mais
c'est plus ce que c'était
qui seul c'est un peu chiche et e s que
vous accordez plus de circonstances
atténuantes un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes où un jeune qui tapent sur des
vieux j'aime pas les jeunes qui tapent
sur des vieux je préfère un vieux qui se
tape une jeune si elle est consentante
et ben voilà bien alors là c'est sérieux
on est tous les deux bloqués dans un
chalet oui la 4 mètres de neige
oui je meurs de faim oui et pour pas
mourir de faim vous me manger vous
commencez par quoi résidents je vais
vous le dire par l'oreille aux parce que
quand je vais au restaurant quelques
fois j'adore manger les oreilles de
cochon
[Rires]
j'ai pas ajouter et parce que le placer
les oreilles et la queue de cochon et
que ça fait attention président
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le plus plaisir
maintenant oui moi de vivre c'est un
bonheur formidable d'être libres d'être
aujourd'hui
d'un autre côté j'étais dans le xvème
oui où il ya des tours etc
j'avais un bureau splendide j'avais de
vue sur la joue surtout paris et puis un
poème d'apollinaire sur le pont mirabeau
maintenant je suis dans 9e du côté de la
rue montmartre c'est formidable s'est
plaint de bistrot où il ya une vie quoi
comme bas nationaux moi j'ai pas de
bagnole non j'en avais eu une avancée et
mes collègues m'ont offert en partant
une carte orange je découvre le métro
sur ses émouvants je découvre pas je
connais j'ai pris le métro dans mon
enfance dans ma jeunesse beaucoup c'est
vrai disons le ce a fait une vingtaine
d'années que j'ai pris le métro vient
pas de lui aujourd'hui au visuel et que
j'ai toujours été à des postes de
responsabilité qu une voiture et un
chauffeur
mais je reprends le métro avec un
plaisir formidable peux même vous dire
que l'autre jour j'étais à une réunion
du quai d'orsay et j'ai pris le métro à
l'assemblée nationale direction porte de
la chapelle qui est la bougie
j'ai changé j'ai pris créteil pour
descendre un grand boulevard est allé
la bombe sur cinq ans
maintenant je vais faire tant pis pour
vous une interview nul dans les bouches
pendant single
[Applaudissements]
j'espère comme suit baptiste vos fils
une baffe y est convaincu convaincu
baptiste aussi cette famille de mon mari
va se marier
ah oui c'est une tradition familiale
d'alison chez vous mes convictions
d'accord je respecte toutes les
convictions tout celle là surtout celle
là oui alors interview nul donc j'ai les
questions très très con je pourrais
prendre kronwall
bah y'a pas toi moi je sais bien les
poser je pense à la cour alors est ce
que vous préférez pierre ou ginette
j'avais dit que c'est qu'on s'est on
parle des mêmes ouais parce qu'il va
beaucoup de bière énergie ces votes
votre pierre votre papa pierre et votre
moment ginette non pas faire un choix
entre ses paras s'il faut avant tout les
deux c'est un formidable et 2 donc doit
pas choisir sincèrement vous arrivez pas
là non non entre hitler et staline vous
préférez qui
à vous en foutez c'est pas vos parents
là c'est pareil je vois pas de
différence
tous les deux non il n'y a pas de
troisième à choisir j'aurais ma faute
c'est tout mais c est pire encore bien
alors vous partez dans un vaisseau
spatial pendant trois ans je crains le
pire
alors j'ai une île déserte avec qui
danser le vaisseau spatial avec qui vous
préféré partir cantona tapis ou locaux
tapie un récent problème
au moins je vais apprendre les choses ah
ouais ça si je voudrais apprendre des
trucs alors j'ai pas négativement on
aime on n'aime pas ouais mais il laisse
pas indifférent ah oui c'est moi j'ai
beaucoup appris il m'a dit beaucoup de
vérité est-ce que vous préféreriez
mourir tout de suite là maintenant pas
vraiment et aller au paradis ou vivre
trente ans de plus et aller en enfer
je prends les trente ans ouais pas grave
après vivre sur terre le corps n'est sûr
de rien après la procession ce pas
d'accord qui gardent khaled les heures
qui arrivent
elle est bien cette idée de gerde a
préféré partir avec une fille très moche
ou un mec très beau
voilà la pêche ouais alors la pêche au
thon
alors autant alors ouais c'est dur mais
c'est qu'elles sont contre et c'est
vraiment con j'ai répondu comme un gars
là je suis pas bon avec la fille quand
même un fils très moche ouais de taper
des du tout non vraiment points n'ont
pas non plus vraiment sûre si le désert
parti rien comparé à chaque fois si vous
partez sur une île déserte d'être là
même à mon avis alors allez y avait
presque spatiale vous savez maintenant
et avec vous là j'y vais pas merci allez
les filles qui envoient des emails en
plus d'un mois si samuel le bihan vu une
fille moche c'est si guillaume canet
avait une fille moche je suis d'accord
vous voyez quoi ou parier fille moche ou
m vous savez moi je m'excuse mais très
beau système
c'est la question
donc c'est pour les filles s'est
inversée oui je sais pas je n'ai pas
versé de l'eau alors qu'elle est moche
ouais mec très moche très moche que va
filtrer bastia un mec très moche se
trouve il est très intelligent il a fait
une très belle est forcément très qu'on
souhaite
ça m'arrange
bien celle-là et terry vous préféreriez
adopter des jumeaux cleptomane ou des
jumelles pyromanes j'avais averti
cleptomane alors des jumeaux cleptomane
oui parce que des jumelles si romain
dans la région vous vivez en plus voilà
c'est mieux que les poteaux moi ça
ramène des trucs à la maison et je peux
être regardé en slip de sega en slip de
tibéri ou en slip de delanoë en fait pas
considéré comme vous je pense que tu
cites
donc maintenant on va vous faire c'est
terrible c'est ici c'est vraiment embêté
que ça tombe sur vous mais bon en même
temps c'est l'interview nul en les
bouches pendant les tigres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
bien vous préférez hitler ou staline ni
l'un ni l'autre à faut choisir
camaraderie triche bien emmerdés c'est
impossible de répondre à une question il
ya quelques années un communiste aurait
répondu c'est à dire oui les temps
changent quand même de tam derksen jing
comme disait bob dylan ouest à l'erp
ouais alors vous devez partir de 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial fameux vaisseau
spatial tête très abîmée depuis le temps
vous préféré partir avec alain duhamel
arlette chabot a je sais où jean pierre
elkabbach
avec ça je sais c'est terrible
choisissez le moins pire ouais je prends
de la femme arlette chabot arlette
chabot volume d'affaires vous préférez
un président de la république d'extrême
droite élu au suffrage universel ou
annuler le processus démocratique
annuler le processus démocratique s'est
passé en algérie
vous préférez annuler le processus d je
préfère annuler profite à un moment
aussi un peu dans la pluie d'extrême
droite et mme chan atomique donc vous
n'êtes pas démocrate pas démocratique
on est on peut pas démocrate jusqu'au
bout avec d'accord pas de liberté pour
les ennemis de la liberté quoi un peu
way dont vous n'êtes pas complètement
changé encore non mais ça viendra
peut-être mais sur cette question là
j'aimerais pas changé oui vous aimeriez
avoir un nez supplémentaires un doigt
supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires années supplémentaires
ça me servira à rien c'est que
supplémentaire qu'on peut compliquer un
doigt supplémentaire doit marquer oui
exactement avec ce défi en plus oui mais
c'est un vrai show sexy vous pourriez
avoir un sexe de filles
ouais non je le dois savoir plus ce
texte donne un sexe de fil ça vous plaît
non non non non c'est dur à gérer
oui c'est dur à gérer vous savez ça vous
mais vous n'aurez plus besoin de
l'alsacien ce moment là j'ai bien bossé
histoire d'alsaciens savait que si on a
deux sexes vaut mieux avoir une voiture
plus longue mais sur le fil 4 ans de
mariage
à votre avis quel est le sport le plus
con j'ai pas un sport que j'aime pas
parce que le coup le curling
j'allais le dire bravo chaque saison
mais c'est ça oui c'est celui que je
vais vous citer way le curling c'est
qu'on le coeur il ya un mec qui balaie
tu veux mais il ya un mec qui balaient
devant un truc là on fait c'est quoi le
sport le plus con pour vous le cricket
parce qu'il est compliqué ouais vous
vois le mec qui se déchire à chelsea si
vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi si j'étais en vendant
un sex-shop je serai quoi nous fonde en
latex
non non une cassette vidéo
ouais c'est bien il faut dans le texte
pourquoi one rouge vous vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien tous les jours
tous les jours alors imaginez vous
deviez partir sur une île déserte
oui quand je le laisserais bien sûr vous
partiriez avec une frite d'esprit vous
partiriez avec une fille très moche ou
un mec très beau
non je vais vous décevoir non avec un
maître bau donc vous êtes un peu non
mais je préfère le bo a ouai mais qu'est
ce que vous feriez sens et il joue les
deux on verra avec magna ne sera pas
dégelé femme n'est pas complètement
fermée au truc quand même mois aux actes
allez vous partagez avec quoi échauder
bien faire - en moi je suis en tout cas
tout le moins en moins moi je vous dis
une semaine c'est un mec très beau à qui
attribuez vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles moins
jeunes qui tapent sur des villas au
moins de quelques petites quelques
raisons de le faire assad mais en même
temps c'est courant mais moi ça me pour
plus que dans le viiième d'un coeur dans
le 8ème c'est plutôt les vieux qui se
tape des petites comme je suis sidéré
par cette réponse oui bah moi aussi oui
c'est comme le fait qu'il parte avec un
meilleur accès des plus naturels si
j'ose dire c'est peut-être critiquable
mais c'est aujourd'hui c'est plus
naturel que quand on est un jeune de
taper sur les vieilles moi je trouve ça
plus naturellement
imaginez que vous vous réincarner en
slip vous préféreriez être le slip de
françois hollande
j'essaie c'est dur de laurent fabius
vas-tu te parle en dehors du parti
socialiste vous n'avez pas d'autre nom
du respect de qui patrick je vais
essayer de faire en sorte de ne pas
penser au slip et puis je dirais henri
emmanuelli mais c'est normal c'est celui
qui est le plus proche de vos idées mais
bon c'était pas une sas chiche
il vaut mieux aussi l'interview il vaut
mieux être riche et qu'on use
intelligent et pauvres
pour intelligent et pauvres intelligent
et pau oui d'accord avec sa façon on est
intelligent il rit je suis pas mal non
plus oui je fais mieux dans ça c'est une
question qu'il est arrivé par e-mail de
jean-philippe de liège encore un belge
ouais et vous préféreriez quoi alors est
riche et quant aux intelligents et
pauvres je sais qu'on va faire
maintenant
une interview qui s'appelle l'interview
nulle part alors première question est
ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère
ça dépend des moments de ma vie ouais
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
je n'ai ni l'un ni l'autre alors vous
devez partir de 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial vous préféré partir avec gérard
muller au moins leur parler serge
klarsfeld ou elie wiesel conduit ni
d'idées mais ce soir on ne peut discuter
discussion combien de temps dans l'es23
en 3 ans et 3 ans
les deux autres trois en fait les
visuels 7 ans et là il est libre alors
savez vous ce qu'est devenu jean roucas
non est ce que vous préférez un
président d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel où on annule les
élections ont déjà nul vous avez vu ce
que ça a donné en algérie quand on a dû
les élections parce qu'elle nous
déplaisaient pour moi je lui aussi à des
élections il ya des élections
gérard ben je me permets de rappeler m
février trek il sait aussi bien que
n'importe qui qui est clair est venu au
pouvoir par des élections
mussolini aussi par exemple mais c'est
bien pour ça le disais tout à l'heure
que les allemands et les nazis c'était
la même chose mais je les la laonnoise
légèrement mieux plus solides comme
hitler c'est vraiment les élections oui
le problème de la démocratie c'est
qu'elle est assez fait pour laisser
parfois venir à sa tête des gens qui
veulent la détruire contre le démocrate
libby
je trouve simplement qu'il faut faire en
sorte que les ennemis de la démocratie
n'est pas la possibilité tout le temps
une baisse limitée
c'est ça moi j'suis bruno grossi si vous
pouviez avoir un truc en plus vous
choisiriez un nez et un oeil ou un saint
comme adamo 3,5
oui ah bon rainy day ou un saint lô
l'oeil derrière bridier vous partez sur
une île déserte pendant deux ans cette
fois vous préféré partir avec un maître
très beau ou une fille très moche je
suis très moche en deux ans deux ans et
déjà parti avec jarre milliards dans
l'espace
je ne demande pas pardon
aux éditions
rocher tandis que ça vous arrive on va
faire l'interview nul on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline c'est très difficile hitler
certainement pas évident non plus mais
enfin de deux mois je choisirais plutôt
maline d'accord parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens pas finance pas pour ça mais
parce que je crois qu'il peut être une
certaine époque que certaines choses
l'idée reçue par et même si j'étais
totalement dénaturé alors vous devez
partir trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
vous avez le choix entre jean pierre
chevènement quelle horreur jean louis
debré à jean marie le pen
c'est abominable ouais je crois que je
pars avec jean pierre chevènement mais
avant de partir je me débrouille pour
que se crée dans le territoire de
belfort un mouvement indépendantiste
très virulente pour qu'il attendrait son
retour est quelqu un qui vous accorder
le plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles non il
ya aucune circonstance atténuante c'est
pas possible souvent cas pour olympiens
ça va pas rigoler en corse la vague anti
loin de chez elle vous touchez à des
choses qui sont sacrées chez nous les
enfants et les vieillards
chez nous aussi ancien vous inquiétez
pas ce qui vous gênerait le plus ça
serait d'être surpris c'est un jeu de
l'esprit par l'âme d'être surpris au lit
avec un mec deux filles avec un mec qui
me paraît difficile pour le moment ça
peut changer mon fin pour le moment il y
ce qui me gênerait le plus beau c'est
d'être surpris au lit avec un mec avec
deux filles avec un mac et vous aussi
compte tenu de ce que vous dites là ça
serait ça me gênerait d'être surprise au
lit avec un mec vous aimeriez avoir
années supplémentaires un acte
supplémentaire un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires un oeil
derrière derrière c'est normal c'est la
corse
on est bloqué tous les deux dans une
bergerie dans la montagne doux et moi il
ya la police française tout autour qui
nous assiège the winners de raisons pas
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on est des
on a pris le maquis en et délais c'est
un jeu de l'esprit un jeu meurent de
froid ce qui fait froid d'abord je meurs
de froid une bergerie de haute montagne
oui je meurs de froid est obligé de me
manger vous commencez par quoi on ne
peut pas arriver ça sud est bloqué dans
une bergerie avec moi et qu'on est
susceptible d'être encerclés par la
police sur un tunnel c'est qu'un
actionnaire
et oui comme votre groupe s'appelait
laisse tout et que laisse tout ça veut
dire les nuls
je vous faire l'interview nul en ne
bouge pas pendant le tignard on ne bouge
pas on en est
la bouche pendant le team call you move
du ring de music no vous avez bougé par
la musique non les caf au légué est ce
que vous préférez votre père votre mère
phare de joie leclerc est vivant et
vivant est ce que vous préférez staline
ou hitler
heatley mais en vêtements le provocateur
que c'est nous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial est ce que vous
préférez partir free space ship
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec
madonna mariah carey jennifer lopez
britney spears ou janet jackson le film
pose les pieds sur terre d'accueil alors
vous devez partir sur une île déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou avec une fille très
laide
oui corre gillet qui fit très laide
oui les mecs très beau c'est vraiment
des casses pieds et vous christian ont
peu varié partir les km très beau une
fille très laide pareil
[Musique]
bien dit le mot le plus con en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore ou oui oui
votre commission préférées est ce que
c'est d'être peint ces mordus ou piquer
lightbeam bien à j'avais entendu vous le
saurez les filles si vous deviez rayer
une ville de la carte laquelle je
n'étais sans gêne et sans voiture avait
sur lui ou de quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux et pourra les ijen
tauriel de mauraige est ce que vous
allez mourir comme otis redding dans un
crash d'avion comme john lennon abattu à
bout portant
comme john bonham le batteur de led
zeppelin qui est mort en s'étouffant
dans son vomi et oui je ne dis pas que
je sais c'est la vérité c'est l'histoire
du rock'n'roll j'aime bien c'est comme
ça et oui ou comme janis joplin d'une
overdose un accident d'avion comme otis
redding l'accident d'avion aucune
culpabilité pas d'erreur iggy si vous
étiez en vente dans un sex shop vous
voudriez être quoi
à un soutien-gorge loisirs
rien de trop question si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex-shop doit y être quoi
une crème monsieur séville dernière
question unicoop une question stupide
mais qui n'est pas de moi celle là
aimez-vous les chiens oui oui encore
comment il s'appelle trombe à iggy pop
milano son nouveau cd rom ou l écueil
la boucle est bouclée
[Musique]
jacques diouf en sommeil merci d'être
venu bebop et à bientôt et garder la
france perd
[Musique]
dieu on ne bouge pas pendant le team ne
tournait pas de tourner pour le bouge
pas pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
thierry roland est ce que vous préférez
staline ou hitler vous dire ni votre nom
les gens qui dit jeu tallinn à un peu
mieux non non vous c'est pareil wes kaka
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore
ou oui oui oui oui c'est que un truc
pareil
merci ses congés ainsi cédé merci c'est
vraiment né là merci madame merci pour
le petit cadeau non c'est nul et bouge
encore encore bravo ses coûts non je
trouve ça très bien mais c'est fatigant
alors vous portez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
vous avez le choix entre trois passagers
gérard holtz
ça commence bien
charles bietry y est gérard muller et
j'ai eu chaud que l'épaule
enfin et c'est suffisamment pour savoir
si véro bien sûr je sais qu'il aime
vivait à 3 minutes les trois ans ouais
bon cheval isabelle alonso oh là là là
je vais vous surprendre
oui j'ai vous surprend ouais je
prendrais gérard holtz bah oui parce que
moi vous parlerez de sport et toi alors
que miller j'essaierai de le gérer de le
convaincre que j'suis pas les normes
merdre qui croient que je suis est
sexuellement ça vous dérange pas de pas
prendre alonso non bons acquis
accordez-vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieux qui se
tape des lingettes jetables des jeunes
déjà lieu du sexe opposé
oui
déjà je croyais que c'était des mecs un
ami entre chez vous il avance chez vous
il va dans votre chambre à l'improviste
ce qui vous gêne le plus qu'ils trouvent
sur la table de chevet c'est mein kampf
ou un godemiché mein kampf avec ouais
bien alors vous préféreriez passé la
nuit avec anne sinclair lors sinclair ou
bob sinclair lors sinclair lors sinclair
pas très gentil pour anne sinclair quand
même c'est pas grave
donc comme canal c'est les nuls
on va vous faire une interview nul
[Applaudissements]
et le graphisme ne passera pas non mais
là il savait la carie ce que vous êtes
prêts
est ce que vous préférez staline ou
hitler staline a dérivé il est devenu
l'un des pires tyrans et il a fait un
mal abominable et des millions de gens
mais au départ il s'agissait d'aider
l'ensemble de la population pauvre
bouzid passe en mémoire de votre père
non non non donc salines un peu mieux un
peu moins mal ouais parce qu'il a tué
plus de gens puissent était pas un
génocide
ouais il n'avait pas décréter que c'est
quand on envoie des gens en sibérie
enfin maintenant mais il n'avait pas
décréter qu'une race devait être
détruite et une classe lui et pourquoi
tu mets pas ma ou danton quiz on
pourrait le mettre
je le garde pour philippe sollers
d'accord vous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
vous partez avec qui charles biétry
guillaume durand ou michel toulouse
jamin mannequin way toulouse quand même
il a dit et toulouse parce qu'il a il a
une imagination que le
quelque chose a perverti sans doute dans
son application mais il continuait
d'avoir une imagination qui va être
intéressante et réjouissante dans ce
voyage face au feu nourri de skeeter
trois ans quand même bien si c'est pour
écouter les histoires de durant pendant
pendant trois révolutions il pas vaincu
billetterie pourra pas me commenter les
matchs en direct voilà d'accord est ce
que vous préférez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau une
fille très laide
ah ouais vous êtes à [__] du tout j'ai
tellement de copains au mot que je pense
que si j'étais un soupçon d' homo ça ce
serait moi je le serai ouais ça se sait
qu'il est condamné mais bon demandez lui
ce que vous préféreriez vous réincarner
en or patrick le lay le patron de tf1
marc tessier le patron de france
télévisions où nicolas de tavernost le
patron de m6 eh ben je vais vous dire un
truc les way
patrick le lay parce que ce qui m'est
pas défendable dans votre bouquin sur
lui la passe c'est pas une vraie
détestation vraiment ce qu'on croyait il
vous ils vous étonne quand même il
m'étonne pas ce qu'il fait des trucs que
je suis incapable de fait qui merite
deux claques et puis surtout un type qui
vers 40 ans alors qu'il a construit des
autoroutes les grands bâtiments des
plats des plateformes de de pétrole au
large de l'océan
oui lui dit francis lui dit patrick up
la télé ici mais après on peut discuter
plein de détails plein de manière plate
forme mais sur le fond quel boulot est
magnifique
est ce que vous savez vous lécher la
langue ah non essayez là essaye de te
lécher la main dit impossible mais si tu
veux mon possible toutes les chaînes en
langue est ce que tu fais de regarder
les yeux
si vous aviez un perroquet oui est ce
que voulait apprendriez comme phrase qui
devrait répéter comme ça toute la
journée moins de chalets tu dois fermer
le gaz tu as pensé à la capote ou coco
arrête là coco tu à fermer le gaz
1 parce que j'ai une famille maintenant
faut que je pense à tout le monde
d'accord est-ce que vous accepteriez de
mourir comme ça là maintenant si ça veut
dire il ya peu de chances à priori 6 sv
éradiquer pour toujours la pauvreté sur
la terre non non parce que c'est une
question vous êtes bien jésus-christ un
nom à dax perd mais ça vous le saviez
vous c'était dans tes fiches au départ
c'est trop facile de dire un mot oui je
suis prêt à mourir tout de suite vous
savez bien que je le ferai quand ça si
c'était possible une fois ci c'était
possible je le ferai comme avec des oui
on le fait est-ce que vous préféreriez
mourir alors attention c'est très grave
ça comme otis redding dans un crash
d'avion comme john lennon abattu comme
janis joplin dans une overdose ou comme
le mec des 6-10 y est étouffé par son
vomi évidemment otis redding ouais
marqueurs ce qu'on fait c'est bien parti
mais qui reste à los angeles je continue
à croître beaucoup d'avions jusqu'à
pâques
- qu'ériger patelin voilà est-ce que
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaire est un peu court les
supplémentaires
un homme supplémentaire attention un
doigt supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires
un doigt un doigt toi tu prends la porte
fort bien les deux en même temps il
parle plus qu'avec jules dassin il met
pas la main sur la cuisse ça joue aussi
gilbert site mettait la main sur la
cuisse
oui pour pas que tu parles j'ai parfois
souvent je pense qu'il dit vrai pourquoi
ils fêtaient la main sur la passe que ce
n'était pas le moment parce qu'ils
s'étaient parlé maintenant qu'il avait
envie que je parle parce qu'il avait son
truc je voulais pas perdre le fil et
puis et puis la connerie c'est bien beau
mais le voulait il voulait déroulé sont
câblés
et voila quoi c'est gentil ce qui dit
lescure surtout à lens en bouquin oui
c'est une phrase en même temps bah oui
mais bon y'en a pas il y en a alors oui
il aurait beaucoup de phrases qui sont
pas gentils gentils et les méchants à
l'époque de l'acharnement des guignols à
mon endroit il m'avait fait
passer des petits messages pour me dire
me faire dire qu'il n'était pas d'accord
et j'avais trouvé ça très gentil de la
part de pierre parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas obligés de vrais de faire ça quoi
pierre quel est à votre avis le sport le
plus con le fist fucking basij étoiles
de curling aux pires qu'eux
magna histoire de désir
non je ne serais pas étonné que je vous
fasse une interview nul non retirées en
à bochum a pendant le tibia
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez hitler staline
ben laden ou mao ont des causes que vous
vous demandez pas ni aucun des quatre
bas il ya des gens qui disent tallinn
par exemple on béru ouais voilà le
robert lui été relaxé
non non non non aucun des quatre noms
parce qu'en plus j'ai vu ce que j'ai vu
là la lada tchad staline à sotchi
ouais et et il y avait la guide était
vraiment terrorisé quand elle a eu les
espèces de statues de staline falloir la
production de ces dictateurs on peut pas
aimer les dictateurs un peu sophie
marceau dire ça c'est des dictateurs
attention c'est sophie marceau qui est
une grande actrice comme dit mathilde
seigner bien vous devez partir trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial
oui trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
préféré partir avec laure saint clair
qu'il va nous rejoindre tout à l'heure
des as à mme sinclair ou bob sinclair
leur sinclair lors s'incline elle
arrêtait le porno en même temps je le
dis bonjour au scrabble
à qui accorder vous le plus de
circonstances s est pas tombé sur nous
que j'avais du pot à qui accorder vous
le plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieilles je sais pas
mais on va dire a dit l'autre mais bon
c'est mon chalet mais qu'au-delà de 50
ans ils disent aux vieux qui se tape des
petites kahn n'est pas encore dans celle
ça dépend ce que ce qui est petit ce
débat majeur ou pas avec ce sont
maintenant ça peut être que des majeures
avec la loi qui est passée sans heurts
majeurs web
oui parfois des majeurs de 15 ans d'être
excitante aussi le mot le plus con
l'amour et vous vous y connaissez
est-ce que c'est merci encore où
oui oui oui parce que ça rappelle
l'enfance ase appelle les bucs à la
gloire cette courte
je vous pose pas la question son lit non
non non cette question est encore plus
riche de tout
accepteriez-vous d'échanger une
paralysie générale contre la faim de la
famine dans l'afrique subsaharienne la
vache c'est dieu c'est vrai je peux pas
répondre là vous n'êtes pas gentil
finalement moi mais je suis méchant
demandé à mathilde seigner
elodie question alors à qui empruntent
auriez vous le plus volontiers son
cerveau pour une greffe me dit polonais
non non jerry cerveau que j'aime
beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup donné
alors à qui empruntent feriez-vous et
son cerveau pour une greffe à valéry
giscard d'estaing
nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac me suis
toujours dit que quelques hommes
politiques soient même si je m'en moque
arrivé à ce niveau là c'était quand même
qu'il y est intelligent mais de là à les
leur chercher le cerveau non ça je crois
que non
chirac pourquoi j'irais du président on
aurait pu parce qu'ils voient des coûts
oui donc ce serait vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien pour qu'on se
voit qu'ils sont sales non c'est la
question qu'ont dans l'interview nues
quand ingrate
ouais si vous deviez interdire un truc à
la télé ça serait la pub ou le porno
pour la pub
élections
des scores
c'est
ch 0 vous vous êtes beaucoup moqué au
début de votre carrière avec jean poiret
des interviews à la télévision ce même
été le début de votre carrière
donc vous allez le payer ce soir on va
faire une interview nul on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
michel serrault qu'est ce que tu veux
est-ce que vous préfériez hitler ou
staline
je les ai pas aimé ni les uns ni les
autres parce que j'ai préféré alex et
zavatta oui michel serrault vous devez
partir trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
oui avec quelqu'un oui vous préféré
partir avec fabrice luchini edouard baer
ou josé garcia à cheikh jaber bas par
vue parce que les autres je les connais
je les connais bien je devais beaucoup
maigri lui j'ai pas que je le connais
aussi je vous intéresse edwards un imac
des matières et s'il faut que je les ai
personnage oui il faut qu'ils ce modèle
est un peu qu'il nous mais je pense que
je peux le dire encore des choses les
autres y sont savent ce qu'ils ont à
faire
peut-être trop mais eux lui berne on
peut encore travailler ou que les
cédantes blanc oui allez me gnangnan
sept ans blanc qu'elle amène des des
consommations non ça mon avis et des
paquets cadeaux pour l'unicef à ben ah
bon
est-ce que vous préféreriez michel
serrault faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide très laide ou un mec très
beau je me barre we had me barre
la boue
attention le mot le plus qu en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui non c'est ça va ah oui allez
c'était les chicons mais bon ça va
rejeter n'y ça va hein
c'était terrible c'est qu'on devait le
mettre dans vos questionnaires sahraouis
s'il vous plaît j'étoufferai
la bombe atomique arrive dans 5 minutes
vous faites quoi enfin vous faites quoi
quoi dans les cinq minutes qui vous
reste à vivre
je regarde ma montre jeudi j'ai plus de
4,3 avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit
anne sinclair lors sinclair ou brett
sinclair
la preuve la première dame anne sinclair
bah oui je la connais la scène il fera
plaisir
michel sait bien les enfants
il chante we sont ils sont bien quand il
entendait quand ils sont d'où il malade
il s'en suit
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
c'est montbrial
waouh
à la ligne bleue mans jeu j'adore ce
chien il doit elle a trois ans il est
bon comme toute l'équipe mais il ya une
chose qui est ma femme se rend pas
compte parce que dans ma femme dont je
parle même pas beaucoup je parle elle
tombe pas trop élevé mais elles sont pas
très bien comme parce que mais ça c'est
autre chose
moi quand je vois mon chien j'ai
l'impression de voir une personne est
alors il se dresse il est aussi grand
que moi il à la moustache comme non mais
je non je vous oui ça paraît rigolo
comme ça
je vous dirai ce que tu veux manger
ouais je veux dire est ce que tu crois
qu'il peut devenir un humain je crois
qu'il faut faut arrêter les pétards
il faut arrêter de fumer la moquette
michel à ces élections at a raison mais
il faut faire attention
michel on est tous les deux oui on est
bloqué dans un chalet au tyrol oui il a
beaucoup neigé on peut pas bouger du
chalet oui on a rien à manger
ah je meurs de faim vous êtes obligé de
me manger vous commencez par quelles
parties de mon corps je commencerai
parce que ça me paraît elles sont assez
belle et importante
sa puissante frappe pas mal mal mal je
vais te manger les oreilles au lit non
du bois magnier les doux comme un agneau
verse l'état appelant bachar l'oreille
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est à votre avis
michel serrault le sport le plus con
celui qu'on fait pas à si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex shop vous seriez quoi
je pense qu'ils vont de là dedans j'ai
la mémoire qui fait très vite
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai n'accueille
pas tous genres ne trompe pas c'est ça
oui et toi tu irais je serai thierry
ardisson voir michel serrault nous avons
glissé au sauvetage
éditions florent massot les messieurs c
interview nul en poche
[Musique]
pendant le king alors allons-y pierre
palmade ça tombe sur vous vous devez
partir dans un vaisseau spatial pendant
trois ans est-ce que vous préféré partir
avec elizabeth teissier madame de
fontenay ou nadine de rothschild am et
tessier est déjà dans les étoiles donc
je la trouvais que je la mets qui
d'autre madame de fontenay et miss
france où nadine de rothschild je pense
elle que je connais pas je prendre
nadine nadine d'accord alors jean michel
jarre si vous aviez le choix vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide ou avec un mec très beau
inquiet de peut-être ou peut-être web
stats ouais enfin il faut voir c'est
difficile à sa défense ça dépend de la
laideur et de la beauté c'est très
subjectif la laideur à la cuisse gauche
elle est vraiment moche est quand même
très dirigé ta réponse nous est du sport
cette question merci
alors c'est à vous maintenant le mot le
plus con en amour c'est merci encore
ou oui oui laurie jusqu'au mariage
j'irai à dire le beau le plus con amour
merci le plus con je vais te dire c'est
quelqu'un en qui j'ai dit c'est chez
quelqu'un qui m'a reconnu pendant les
rapports aller et qui j'étais rentré
comme j'ai la personnalité un peu
embrumé moi aussi et c'est pendant les
rapports la personne a ouvert les yeux
aux biens vols me
il faut déstabiliser jean michel est ce
que vous savez vous lécher la langue
[Rires]
non j'ai pas essayé à partir
d'aujourd'hui non mais c'est un bon
dossier nécessaire lors il cite vous
lécher la langue abc si on peut encore
la nation qu'on peut pas mal je sais je
sais je sais enfin il faut s'aider du
palais ouais non pas le voulez chez la
moustache josé laissez-les alors parce
que c'est pas dur si c'est difficile
j'avais blanche et la langue c'est un
peu con mais c'est pas du social
services publics bien attention talent
made nous sommes seuls qui tous les deux
vous et moi d'accord bloqué l'hiver dans
un chalet il fait très froid il ya trois
mètres de neige
on a rien à bouffer je meurs de froid
vous mourrez de faim
vous me manger vous commencez par quoi
demande à joseba veillerette de dire
qu'est ce qui est le meilleur dans ce
cas meilleurs dans leurs discours le
frigo au cuistot un blocus au dollar 10
ans et wauja le bas des oreilles c'est
pas mal la douce à pour commencer
à celles là c'est là les durs jean
michel vous préféreriez être réincarné
en slip de françois hollande
ah je sais que françois bayrou ou de
nicolas sarkozy ça c'est très très dur
ce qui est bien quel est le plus propre
at on alors choisir dans quel ce qu'ils
voulaient très incarné ce que vous savez
que vous serez réincarné en slip jeu
suicide ouais si celui-ci suicide avant
avant d'incarner apparemment quand on se
suicide n'est pas regardée dans
l'oreille vous pierre palmade vous
préféreriez être incarnée en slip de
françois hollande de françois bayrou ou
de nicolas sarkozy comment comment on
peut savoir qu'elle est plus propre
nicolas sarkozy c'est seul que je
connais donc françois bayrou le matin à
passe sans slip palmade
[Applaudissements]
bien alors jean michel jarre ça tombe
sur vous vous préféreriez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion
john lennon un shot à bout portant
janis joplin une ode in over dose ou
comme john bonham le batteur de led zep
qui est mort étouffé dans son vomi
ça c'est pas une question nul sauf le
dernier cas ouais je dirais john lennon
en général moins que ce soit rapide à
bout portant
ouais ouais et vous voilà va je ne
voudrais pas donner des idées aux gens
mais assassiné jeudi à crash d'avion je
suis portrait parent est une ode et
c'est pas terrible si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex-shop vous seriez quoi
je parle a répondu que la caisse ait
marqué c'est tout bête vous intrigue
flatteur locateur jeudi virilement
facteurs d'accord il apparaît
jean michel vous seriez quoi se vêtir en
vente dans un sex-shop un mode d'emploi
penser ça tombe sur vous vous aimeriez
avoir un et supplémentaires un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
voilà ou alors quoi un sexe évidemment
supplémentaire de sexe mariées 2 bon
c'est pas mal bah oui un oeil à neuss et
ça fait un peu mon stand ea qu'un chèque
supplémentaire dans ma co2 jean-michel
sexe d'homme en plus ou un sexe de femme
avons une bonne question alors ça serait
pas mal d'avancé que c'est normal non
plus les deux oies les deux et vous moi
j'ai déjà les deux le pire est à venir
maintenant c'est l'interview nul
on ne bouge pas alors nottingham bien
pour l'aider à olivier si vous voyez
qu'à un moment il a du mal en tant que
vieux copain de débauche vous pouvez
l'aider voilà alors est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère à ses
interviews nul je vous ai prévenus je
préférais mes grands mères
ouais le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous c'est merci alors où oui oui
alors heureuse et pour vous alors oui
oui pour toi c'est quoi le mot le plus
con amant moi je parle pas
imaginez que vous croisiez un
extraterrestre le matin comme ça à
acheter des cigarettes
il vous dit t'es qui toi vous répondez
quoi et toi si vous étiez en vente dans
un sex shop vous seriez quoi en vente
dans un secteur maginez vous soyez quoi
comme objet d'un préservatif mais je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que c'est
exactement la même chose que les
metteurs en scène les préservatifs
ça rassure quand on en main mais quand
il y en a pas qu'est ce que c'est bon
maintenant une question nul qui m'a été
envoyé par email parce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer des questions évidemment par
un gym de béthune savez vous pourquoi
les abribus n'abrite pas les bus je veux
vivre à la question si vous aviez un
père heureux chez vous voulu apprendre
briller quelle phrase tu à fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco je la prendrai à ses acquis
attributs riez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles il le
vieux qui stoppe diriez way
alors vous préféreriez passé la nuit
avec anne sinclair lors sinclair ou
brett sinclair
ben je vivais dire at 5e parce que je
connais pas les deux autres et ça lui
soit plaisir et vous carso non moi je
vois ça je veux pas passer la nuit toute
façon non c'est moi j'ai toujours vu ces
choses là comme une livraison mais ça
veut dire qu'il ya une heure d'arrivée
une heure de départ je voulais vous les
chiens une question de michel drucker
tgp l'icare oui oui tu racontes oui
puisqu'on est généralement je vais
bientôt le voir nos coeurs je vais
bientôt le voir entraîner vous la poser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
drogba fait si ce que c'est c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview nul à vous êtes prêts oui
thierry est ce que vous préférez votre
père ou votre mère
je préfère noël mamère ouais est ce que
vous préférez hitler ou staline à
staline away away qui l'a tué plus de
gens vachement plus 40 millions en plus
donc je pense que le mec est plus fort
et des bulletins des cas alors vous
partez trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
trois ans c'est long à déjà j'y vais pas
c'est long trois ans vous avez le choix
entre trois personnes
thomas valentin le directeur des
programmes de m6 dominique farrugia
le directeur des programmes de canal +
où etienne mougeotte je rêve je
réfléchis même pas à etienne mougeotte a
way or doit bien se marrer avec lui
est ce que vous allez faire l'amour avec
une fille très laide ou un mec très beau
mais en général je préfère tout
simplement faire l'amour etc avec ceux
ou celles qui veulent quoi d'accord sans
que soient obligés des forces parce que
moi je n'aime pas taper et à brigitte
barèges et du showbiz
il y a
bien qu est-ce que tout cela retient htc
passer à l'action
je vais faire julien lepers tu le hais
ce que ferrari s'est réincarné en
bataille ou en fontaine alors attention
un indice ne s'affiche pas sur notre
écran hanninen ni l'un ni l'autre à vos
réponses c'était évidemment la peine en
france comme on applaudit sied pas ça ne
vous rendez compte que vous applaudissez
n'importe quel sera publique de
télévision
tu connais ça vous allez me faire
laplaud drucker on l'a répété
brucker c'est comme ça j'aime faire la
politique
ouais
afin d'offrir des emplois et voilà
bienvenue champs elysées avec michael
sabia bispo patrick bonnel ya c'est bien
on regarde un peu précaire ils ont fait
des programmes à plus de rigueur alors
un ami débarque chez vous à l'improviste
oui ça j'ai pas d'amis ce qui vous gêne
le plus qu'ils trouvent sur votre table
de nuit
mein kampf oui l'effroyable imposture de
thierry meyssan ou un godemiché alors
frange sans hésiter thierry meyssan
parce que je dois vous dire que je les
regardais dans votre émission à thierry
et j'ai fait au [__] mais donc mais
tout les qu'une immense supercherie et
ça se trouve tu plus en sécurité et
après je les ai vus dans d'autres
émissions de télé se faire démonter la
gueule et je me suis aperçu donc cet
homme qui avait l'air ben ma foi assez
gentil était peut-être un petit peu
farfelu ch
donc tu vas dans la science fiction donc
thierry meyssan bonne réponse bien dans
les bars de capotage
si vous aviez un perroquet oui voulu
apprendriez ta ferme et le gaz
tout ce que vous dites ça parce que je
suis d'origine juive oh c'est pas bien
alors applaudissements à la maurice
herzog
fermez le gall ta pensée la capote une
coco arrête là coco je vais dire je vais
dire qu'à penser à éteindre le gaz parce
que chez moi c'est les plaques
électriques pour elle en fut alors vous
préféreriez mourir comme otis redding
dans un crash d'avion
john lennon tué à bout portant claude
françois dans une baignoire avec un si
tu veux je sais pas quoi john bonham le
batteur de led zep étouffé dans son vomi
ou janis joplin par overdose
voilà quel programme art est une star
fois prendre à mourir comme une star
mais quand même je préférais mourir
comme comme comme patrick roy a en parle
pas assez d'eux patrick rondat je trouve
ça bien dommage non comme philippe de
dieuleveult dans l'incertitude la plus
totale
c'est gai cette émission il est mort
qu'est-ce qu'on fait certes il est mort
allez merci c'était super j'ai adoré
michaël youn
non je vais rester
est-ce que vous préféreriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
a indiqué que moi un sexe
supplémentaires pourquoi pourquoi pas ce
que je vais vous dire la vérité
ballet match ce soir le jour de la
distribution des beats way
malheureusement dans la file d'attenté
gt gt à la fin et donc j'ai eu un jeu
j'en ai une merde quoi
c'est exact dans une émission fait
l'interview ne le dit à oui oui je
crains qu'elle ne souhaiterait nul des
ailes
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère mon père j'ai pas eu le temps
de m'en lasser parce que j'ai eu un père
très distrait donc de temps en temps il
y en a qui me qui attrapent les kim
étrangler complètement tout ça je me dis
j'ai eu peur c'était beau père et puis
j'avais plus de nouvelles pendant 50 ans
bon père bon voila mon père c'était ça
quant à ma mère
ma mère c'est devenu un personnage de
fiction
j'en ai fait un personnage sur scène on
ne se voit plus beaucoup
je pense que
elle n'était pas dans la rue le premier
maire dans les manifestants non non non
non lisa minutes y'a prescription est
l'étagé préfériez staline ou hitler il
faudrait compter les morts parmi
lesquels des deux tués le plus c'est les
jeux je refuse de me prononcer je
préfère corbacho of key qui a été
épatant et c'est une des plus grandes
injustices des histoires que combats de
chauffe n'ai pas réussi à faire ce qu'il
voulait la pérestroïka et qu'on ait mis
ce soûlard de delsinne et maintenant
cette extraordinaire serial killer qui
est in
il me fait peur lui quand j'ai vu le
camp du bien
avec bush le champion de la peine de
mort
poutine le tueur de tchétchènes et yann
ces mines l'homme de la place tiananmen
le camp du bien
mais ce spécial vous partez trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial
ça va être une connerie non non on
revient un peu à la politique française
vous préféré partir avec sarkozy juppé
ou alliot marie allez je comprends il
peut dire c'est pas facile comme j'ai du
coeur et je pars à mega lieu maryse la
belle eau
alors si vous aviez le choix ou
préfériez faire l'amour avec une fille
moche très moche ou un mec très beaux
objets depuis que je veux tu iras que je
vais chez toi tu ira peut-être ce
frisson me faire [__] une question
qui vous concerne
à qui accordez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ya des
vieilles jour des nerfs ventre
accepteriez-vous guy bedos d'échanger
une paralysie générale tefal aurait agi
contre la faim de la famine en afrique
non vraiment si jamais si jamais la
paralysie vrai je demanderai comme la
fille lac ont avoué
donc là je demanderai l'euthanasie le
droit de mourir dans la dignité pour moi
c'est quelque chose de fantastique donc
alors d'accord seulement afrique la
tétraplégie et l'euthanasie derrière
voilà la classe bien je veux bien parce
que je suis un peu fatigué oui se voit
pas trop ah si vous aviez un perroquet
voulu apprendriez ta ferme et le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco ses conséquences et ses services
publics en même temps qu est la coke ou
[__] mais qui c'est qui a préparé ces
mois constitue prise sur les prix la
quelle est à votre avis le sport le plus
con moi je veux pas peur des clients un
vendanges en est là pour vous le curling
qui 6 1 c'est là où il ya un mec qui
balaient devant la truck qu'avance tu
sais ah oui oui messi considéré comme
bien entendu tellement de mecs qui font
du curling qui vont voir le spectacle
toute façon - non non oui je prends pas
de grands risques
elle est d'accord je cherche sa nouvelle
coupe
ce sens mais avant il s'était marié être
réincarné en marguerite duras soit en
miles monroe a je crois là au point où
on en est en marie malroux parce que
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour arthur
muller j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
j'ai même adapté une de ses pièces et
avoir une histoire d'amour totalement
virtuel avec arthur muller et des normes
ni bar j'ai une légère réaction là rien
qui avance est préféré à un président de
la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout un président de la république
d'extrême droite
la question est mal formulée ça ne va
pas ensemble
il n'y a pas de république d'extrême
droite et à l'extrême droite où il ya la
république
maintenant ça va être dur pour vous les
fagots la ligne jaune habitat qu'est ce
qui va lui dire very tough les nivernais
forest quoi oui d'accord interview nul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à lévis kravitz ya est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère est
super d'interviews et old before rien
non mais moi j'étais fissa fissa maman
est ce que vous préférez lennon
mccartney vient d'annoncer tu es
quelqu'un sait ce qu'il a fait tout seul
c'était quelque chose vous préférez
jagger richards s'est glissé t il à ces
jours là ils ont mon numéro de téléphone
ainsi que ces deux personnes
vous avez travaillé avec mick jagger sur
son disque solo vous savez à quoi on me
rende pas avoir un sens l'autre de
numéros en même temps êtes vous en
sortez bien question suivante si vous
aviez le choix est ce que vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide ou un mec très beau je pense
que je prendrai la fillette
vous devez partir trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial lenny kravitz est ce
que vous préféreriez partir avec kylie
minogue natalia imbruglia ou vanessa
paradis c'est vanessa là où elle a déjà
quelqu'un pour l'instant c'est pas
possible sinon tutti 3 voilà très bien
là toutes les trois est-ce que vous
préféreriez vous réincarner en elvis
presley bob dylan ou eminem terlet
badiane dylan la bombe atomique va
tomber dans cinq minutes
vous faites quoi l'amour avec ses deux
filles
ok non ma régime à bienne be
ça va très bien a simulé à tapotage
capotage vous trouvez votre fiancée au
lit avec un homme
qu'est ce que vous faites vous les
rejoignez vous frapper l'homme où vous
pleurez oui oui
allons-y rejoignant lake d'accord alors
il est cocu mais sympa mais qui est sûr
très importante pour vous qui êtes une
star du rock est ce que vous préféreriez
mourir comme otis redding dans un crash
d'avion comme john lennon tué à bout
portant
comme john bonham
étouffé par votre vos mii ou est-ce que
vous préféreriez mourir comme janis
joplin d'une overdose afin qu'à je pense
que la mort de diana la cité du doudou
plus oui si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop
que seriez-vous comme objet a ni eau à
gaz mais chéri j'ai ce que la machine un
orgasme m
le mot le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous est ce que c'est
merci merci ce type là rôle à la rendre
si tu vois est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui au lycée mais vous qu'est-ce
que vous passez une fille comme ça c'est
ce que j'aime encore comme vous avez dit
que cette émission était parfois nul
bah vous allez avoir droit michel
serrault à une interview nul
michel serrault vous devez partir vous
devez partir
michel serrault je dois parties devaient
partir trois ans ou alors tu me croisant
dans un vaisseau spatial avec quelqu'un
vous êtes deux dans ce vaisseau spatial
vous devez partir est ce que vous
choisissez thierry ardisson marc olivier
fogiel ou co et trois ans dans le
vaisseau spatial ben je crois que je
t'emmène c'est gentil non mais
actuellement ils essaient de deux points
c'est un peu les gens pour que cette
soirée où cette émission est un peu de
piment et c'est normal est anormal mais
tu sais ce que tu as tu un bon fond
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu n'es pas
méchant mais c'est bien qu'ils ont
quelquefois un peu bête mais
michel est ce que vous préférez être
peint ces mordus ou piquer piqué et je
le suis dit est-ce que vous accepteriez
d'échanger une paralysie générale contre
la fin définitive des inondations au
bangladesh paralysie générale aux gens
c'est la montre la fin des inondations
bangladesh en même temps ben oui oui
c'est intéressant je veux sauver des
vies 1
il faut que je consulte un avocat tu
seras paralysé jusqu'à la fin de tes
jours mais on faisait partie du jeu
écoute franchement de mentir pour l'eau
aujourd'hui un style jazzy je peux pas
te répondrais je comprends quand j'irai
un peu moins bien il te dira et à l'once
d'or
[Applaudissements]
si vous disparaissez michel serrault
acquis confieriez-vous votre enfant à
fabrice luchini ou à pierre arditi jeu
au couple il car ils font vraiment
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
vous avez commis un crime à qui demander
vous de cacher le corps aux gendarmes
avoir sur aux gendarmes et aux parents
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
michel la limace michel serrault est-ce
que vous préféreriez mourir tout de
suite là maintenant et aller au paradis
ou vivre trente ans de plus et aller en
enfer en je crois que je
la vérification intéressante vas-y on
est tous les deux dans un chalet à la
neige en quelle horreur il fait pas toi
la mer et il fait très froid on peut pas
sortir du chalet on a pu en a mangé
oui vous êtes obligé de me manger vous
commencez par quelles parties de mon
corps fait pas pour que ce soit plus
simple sans vrai un peu de fond de teint
beaucoup
bien souvent d'être effectivement et il
est encore plus bête non alors que vous
préférez oui un président de la
république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout je pense que les s'il n'y a pas de
choix parce que c'est pareil
vous pouvez lire ou laisser faire les
choses
je pense qu'ils ont le même résultat
michel serrault michel tient très bon ça
moi michel serrault aimeriez-vous avoir
un nez supplémentaires oui un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe et supplémentaires en fait
embêté parce que je pensais que tu
verras prêt mais ça peut servir non non
ce qui m'embête c'est avec son doigt l'a
carrément à un doigt dans le nez c'est
pas très joli comme une question c'est
quand même j'aurais pas fait ça avec
aulas il avait un col romain il c'était
autre chose de la débandade
dernière question la plus importante
michel serrault oui vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien
eh ben ça va tu es toni pourrait être
deux fois par jour non
je
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu